your mission should you choose to accept  it I wonder did you ever choose not to  [Music]  the end form was feared is going  and the blood will be on your hands the  fallout of all your good intentions you  had a terrible choice to make in Berlin  one life over millions and now the world  is at risk this is the CIA's mission if  he had held on to the plutonium we  wouldn't be having this conversation  this Tim you'd be dead yes they would  that's the job  [Music]  you don't understand what you're  involved in you need to walk away please  don't make me codes for you how many  times has hunts government's betrayed  him disavowed him cast him aside how  long before a man like that has had  enough  we are  so how is he oh you know same always  there  what the hell are you doing find it best  not to hook  you